howdy-ho reject nation I'm Greg Alba
I'm John Humphrey we're gonna watch a
horror movie trailer from Darren lianbao
husband st. Agatha Oh John this is John
is a horror movie fan and is a Darrin
hland Bausman fan I have seen four of
his movies
so saws two three and four you start at
three oh wow yeah I thought you were the
let's move on I know one of our top
tiers on patreon is whatever video your
request we must definitely do a put up
on youtubes and today comes from our
great friend Jess um DeLong this is
produced from one of his friends Sarah
summit team Michaels triple who just
sounds hot sure why not trying to land a
gig here oh yeah no it's the hottest
name either old man burning up in here
better put these headphones on
dragonblood we take care of women like
you okay all come to this convent must
leave behind their formulas and
possessions mother's approval is all you
should concern yourself with I believe
they can be a blessing
don't trust these [ __ ] I do what is
going on Mary saw something face my
policies are strict but they are there
for a reason we operate under a strict
vow of silence it is closer to the Lord
your pain only brings you closer to him
there is no wrong right in this place
there's choosing not to see it
[Music]
[Music]
for your continued making it will bring
them nothing but pain
[Applause]
[Music]
I have a right nipple joke yeah yeah is
that uh is that a good is it a good
thing or is that like a halfway point
and a halfway point halfway awesome try
to figure this out it's not a rating
system my nipples I apologize that's
what I thought I thought you know two
nips is like a hundred percent no man
that's not the way it works at all it's
just way my body reacts to certain
triple chills oh that means five stars
yeah two ratings 500 that's creepy
yeah I want a movie about Catholicism
today that is good that is about love
and forgiveness and accepting Jesus in
your heart says right now it just seems
like evil Catholicism is in hey man well
there are plenty of faith-based films
you can check out Christian I am NOT
talking Christian Catholic I'm talking
Catholic you want movies that'll make
you like feel guilty for even enjoying
them that's what we're looking for as
day and age this is a unique approach
right here going to become a nun finding
out being a nun ain't such a good idea
yeah hey man of all the genres to
research it's nice to see some nuns
Blois tation coming back into the loo is
such a weird niche and I'm just happy
that it's here again because you know we
have like creepy nuns here and there and
certain things specially like American
Horror Story coming back into vogue but
I don't know I feel like the atmosphere
of this look pretty intriguing and and
what I had forgotten about before
sitting down to this is I think this is
the movie that spirals out of his
haunted experience that he and I forget
the other guy's name but he had this
experience called the tension experience
that then became the lust experience
that then became something else and
there are these like immersive theater
pieces and I think this is at least
related to those yeah
how interesting I think that other guy
was Wes Anderson definitely Wesen
amandarrell Impaler or like this you
know I can feel that in there directing
styles if you know Geralyn Bosman films
if you know he has a low budget and he
could do whatever he wants
mmm this is not gonna be an easy
experience it seems like they're gonna
cover all the sins mm-hmm you know what
every movie that's scary that deals with
Catholicism seems to cover you know like
lust and be all the sins we don't get
enough gluttony why don't any of these
nuns getting fat and being condemned for
that you know we covered gluttony since
frickin 7 we need some gluttony in this
movie and some sloth man we need some
slovenly potential nuns just kickin it
not doing much reading like a page of
Bible a day maybe how much more
interested with this movie be if our
main character was obese and couldn't
move I could see a whole 90-minute movie
about her just going evil [ __ ] just
don't want to go downstairs right now
yeah
Oh God that's your st. Agatha movie it
would be like Barry's not way more
intense
that's righted shoot this bad boy guys
make something special yeah seriously
man where's the originality get some
blood did I see any men in this trailer
I don't think so I think there was a guy
in the background at one point well
there was that spooky guy with no face
yeah from the strangers but I'm like
scanning this trailer right now I don't
see an image of a dude here that's even
scarier to me because women in general
terrify me oh yeah so the idea of just
being in a teacher it's watching a bunch
of women who are supposed to be doing
good things start going into some evil
descent territory it sounds crazy oh
yeah one is a male movie goer I know
that I don't think I'll be able to
identify with anything going on on
screen if there are no dudes in it no no
how will I be able to relate it to my
own personal experience I'm right there
with you John
that's one thing we can count on with
Greg and Josh there's no no sorry oh
wait the woman's on the street looks
like there's some like suicide attempts
in here too right as possible like with
the cut arms or the cut wrists and then
you kind of have what's what's the One
Flew Over the Cuckoo's Nest the lady's
name there's ratchet yeah that's kind of
what the the sister here feels like yeah
like a nurse rat like oh you mean well
but no you don't know you're evil yeah
you're gonna be telling us a bunch of
things under the guise of this is what's
right and this is what is pious and what
the Lord wants and it's not going to she
looks too polished though to that nun
she looks way too polished cuz she's got
kind of like you look like you should be
old but you also look really young at
the same time nun that takes really good
care what it looks like yeah I'll give
you got a suspect anyone I don't care
man woman nun priest rabbi especially a
rabbi especially the rabbi as funny as I
believe the lead in this movie was
actually a partner nice no oh yeah yeah
but she was a part of the haunted
experience too so like I've actually in
a weird yeah yeah cuz I didn't get to do
theater macabre or the lust experience
but I did the tension experience twice
and she's like the center figure of that
you know what I like about this for an
essence here no I'm a very sincere no
well I like about this trailers most of
the time you see these trailers with
this kind of premise and it feels like
there will be a lot of build like look
at this glassy looking thing there's a
crow in the distance yeah oh it's all
pretty what's this house all about and
then there's jump scares and then it
builds and then maybe by the very end it
looks a little insane like bleak and
crazy this looked like it's gonna be a
roller coaster yeah looks like it's
gonna be kind of nutty and exploitation
II and yet it just seems like it doesn't
seem like it's interested in being like
some boring slow bill to a cool finale
because you think it's gone from like a
haunting experience
you kind of get that vibe from here if
you check in here and this is the thrill
ride you're gonna get end up becoming a
nun is really a really a sacrilegious
thing yeah well you know when you're in
with these nuns and generally speaking
just the vibes the aesthetics and stuff
like that it looks a little more gothic
and it kind of reminded me of the
conjuring at first and that's sort of
neat territory to see Darrin go to just
because I associate him with a lot more
now that this isn't contemporary but
things that are a bit more modern and
stylish and and sort of crazy and this
looks like a different flavor of crazy
than I'm used to seeing from him so I'm
excited for that well it feels icky and
once and one quote here said perverse
and it does feel that way yeah I don't
feel like it's gonna be a Gore I feel
like there would be some gore I don't
feel like it's gonna be a Gore fest
I feel like it'll be more messed up than
than gory yeah I feels like
psychologically really twisted and
really honing in on punishment for the
inner demons we all have yeah man that's
the only way to truly process things is
to punish yourself to the point that you
truly feel endless remorse hmm and you
never leave that place you know it was
good at that Jason told Jason Dolan
Jason Dolan is constantly punching
himself
you remember The Da Vinci Code the
albino monk was based on Jason Dolan and
hey remember where I learned how to
touch myself I do
I was veiled shame about it I was there
for that I learned that from Jason Dolan
oh wow
by the way is a very talented writer and
is working on his directorial debut I
don't think it's about touching yourself
it could be it might be about touch I
mean yourself it depends you know what
kind of picture it's gonna be I don't
know but hey Jason thanks for requesting
this good luck to all your friends on
this keep a look out for Jason Dolan's I
touch myself movie I think it's gonna be
a sleeper hit oh yeah I can just see the
trailer now slow somber version of uh
touch my so you know I'm you perfect you
never heard this huh
such myself want you to something my
guess my mom would sing that to me
before we go to sleep that's a perfect
lullaby I understand why you're so
well-adjusted yeah my mom and I have a
great relationship these friends are
Jason Dole you seem really cool you guys
should subscribe to the regeneration
click that notification bell and check
us out on patreon why go find out